this series of videos will explore the
basic grammar of the Romance languages
by comparing and contrasting late Latin
and its descendants this first video is
a short introduction providing some
general thoughts before we just jump
right in
the roman empire spread latin as it
conquered its way throughout ancient
europe local popular forms of latin
collectively called vulgar latin
developed over the centuries changing as
languages do into a variety of languages
and dialects across the continent some
of these languages even spread across
the globe and continue to develop far
from their original homes nowadays there
are five major Romance languages French
Spanish Portuguese Italian and Romanian
those are probably names you recognize
but there are other regional languages
like Sicilian and Catalan and extinct
languages like Dalmatian that give us a
more complete picture of this language
family so what is a comparative grammar
of the Romance languages very briefly a
grammar is how a language works so a
Romance grammar will tell you or give
you an idea of how the Romance languages
work this grammar will be comparative
because instead of just looking at
individual languages like just French or
only Spanish we'll explore examples from
multiple languages in each topic
throughout this series I'm going to
display examples on your screen vulgar
latin examples we'll start with an
asterisk that little star is going to
tell you that vulgar latin words are
reconstructed they come from a mostly
undocumented form of Latin if you want
to learn how extinct undocumented
languages are reconstructed I share a
lot more in a separate series covering
the basics of historical linguistics
I'll put a link to that below here's one
example classical Latin writers used
look water for I speak but some late
latin speakers started saying hablo and
others started saying fabulo for i speak
instead examples in languages other than
latin in the modern Romance languages
start with an asterisk
when they offer negative evidence
negative examples are reasonable
structures that tend not to show up in a
language for example English speakers
say my language but don't really say V
my language well in Italian the opposite
is actually true but don't take my word
for these really you can get a taste of
the frequency of any of these examples
by starting to search for similar
structures online positive examples
should come up a lot more frequently
than negative ones
if the negative R even returns any
results at all okay let's divide romance
words up we'll split them up based on
whether or not each word has different
forms in English the word hat as a
plural form hats these kinds of words
are variable other words like two into a
party are invariable in the Romance
languages content words like nouns and
verbs can very well function words like
prepositions and conjunctions tend not
to vary so how do variable words vary
not in any old way variable words vary
in a very specific way they have a base
that carries the meaning like this
Spanish base teeth Union we call this
basis stem endings attached to the end
of this stem and often carry some
grammatical information that Spanish
stem funcion can be used in the verb
when Fiona it works for Fiona it worked
and so on we'll treat these variations
as different forms of the same word not
as completely different words
you
let's build on these ideas in upcoming
lessons as we start to look into how
nouns verbs pronouns adjectives and
adverbs particles and sentences work in
the romance languages I'm really excited
to start sharing some examples with you
you're going to meet some very cool
languages and get a good sense for how
this family works
male:today that's goodbye for now and I
look forward to next time